hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
ryan right today I'm going to be
covering the top stories I've selected
for the third week of May 2015 pitch
perfect 2 opened up to 70 point three
million out doing Mad Max fury road
which opened a 40 4.4 million dollars
Mad Max fury road has a bigger budget
bigger stores considered one of the best
action movies ever and contains a lot of
originality but people would rather
watch hot girls doing acapella first
official photo has been released of the
world of warcraft film adaptation robert
kazinsky as orgrim you know Robert
Kazinsky has a name that sounds similar
to mass murderer richard kuklinski
coincidence probably the director of the
siege and Blood Diamond Head zwick isn't
talks to direct Tom Cruise in the sequel
the jack reacher the sequel will be
called Jack Reacher to jack off reach
around a classic ninja turtles villain
has been rumored for TMNT to the
character's name is Krang Krang is an
alien warlord that comes from Dimension
X which is also one of my favorite porn
sites haitao have marble and Sony found
spider-man's new Norman Osborn it looks
like they may be I Matthew McConaughey
for the role the green goblin has never
been this sexy before and I'm hoping
this time we can see the green a little
goblin you know what I mean
is green penis cinematographer of
Skyfall and prisoners Roger Deakins has
been brought on board to DP for blade
runner to this means even at the film
sucks balls it'll still become worthy
Chris Pratt shuts down rumors of
starring in the Ghostbusters reboot and
indiana jones 5 he said as far as i know
that's complete [ __ ] on a personal
note I thought Chris Pratt was better
when he was fat he was more relatable
alright guys well that's it for my movie
news of the third week of may 2015 if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter and you could also catch my
videos on Latino Review com where any
ethnicity can check it out but Latinos
are put front and center